hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
so a new game has arrived on console
this is dauntless if you kept an eye on
my content over the last few months you
know that I've been looking forward to
dauntless due to the combination of
concept mechanics and that hat style
well it's finally here and I thought
we'd go through eight reasons you should
give it a download and first of all it's
completely free to play let's break it
down over the past few days the creators
of dauntless have kindly given me access
to the build which has gone live on ps4
and Xbox one
right now they're even kind enough to
sponsor this video allowing me to get
this to you on day one so thanks very
much dauntless so the first point is
dauntless is free-to-play anyone can
download the game and playstation
players you do not require PS plus it's
legitimately free-to-play free-to-play
titles have taken a solid foothold in
modern gaming from fortnight to warframe
but dauntless isn't Battle Royale it
isn't a shooter either dauntless is a
game about teaming up with friends to
hunt down behemoths and use their bounty
as means to craft new gear in fact let's
break down the gameplay loop and set the
scene we are Slayers monumental badasses
with one calling in life to hunt down
the hulking great monsters causing havoc
in the Chateau tiles these menaces are
the behemoths who are hostile in nature
and threaten our very existence if we
don't say that then we look like
bloodthirsty heathens murdering the
creatures of the Lamas so if anyone asks
they started it alright the formula is
in three simple steps defeat a behemoth
reap the rewards craft and mod equipment
rinse and repeat go back into the
battlefield and do it all over again
after selecting a bounty wheel and down
on whichever biome that behemoth resides
in nature ice desert you get the idea oh
by the way we can collect natural
crafting materials in each biome too we
are then tasked to find the behemoth and
usually the fight is broken into two
steps
initial combat where you are looking for
weaknesses and tactic
deciding the best way to win the fight
and then the final battle itself usually
after the behemoth has retreated to
another area I've had access to the bill
for a few days and I've already seen so
many behemoths it's daunting hey there's
a there's a joke in there somewhere
each behemoth is unique with individual
design traits and abilities for example
one behemoth hid underground replicating
the game's healing pods quite a shock of
the first time he jumps out another
behemoth used magma to burn my slayer at
every opportunity the behaviour starts
out with basic attacks maybe a rush a
forward roll or a stamping motion but
the more you play leveling up your armor
and weaponry the more behemoths you'll
be able to hunt the battles themselves
come down to two important elements the
weapons and armor you choose pre-fight
and your ability to read the movements
of the behemoth basically body language
small tells to know when to attack and
when to defend the game does a good job
of conveying this information early on
the body language of behemoths in the
early game is profound and easy to
notice but the longer you play the more
subtle they become many battles can be
won with button bashing but soon the
nuances become important for example
this behemoth uses electrical shock
attacks which if they land hurt like
hell but also prevent Slayers from using
consumables and that includes healing
items another beast summons minions
to add an extra dimension to the fight I
guess what I'm saying is variation is
key to this type of game and dauntless
for what I've seen so far has it in
droves to go a little deeper
dauntless encourages you to roll and
evade their behemoths this is quite
important the roll animation has a few
frames which negate all damage they are
invulnerable 80 frames in the game if we
have good timing it will give us a
significant advantage dodging through
attacks to keep up close and personal
with the behemoth we all instinct even
roll away from danger but after a few
hours in dauntless you'll get better
results in rolling towards attacks and
hopefully through them to a degree it's
high-risk high-reward
I'm sure you've noticed by now the
weaponry we have at our disposal as I'm
writing this there are six weapon
classes to get to grips with in
dauntless axe chain blades hammer
repeaters war pike and the good old sod
to choosing the right weapon can depend
on your play style all the beasts you're
going to fight I'll break them all down
in another video coming soon but as a
first step
try them all out go crazy have fun you
may not want to try the chain blades but
after using them you could unleash your
inner Kratos as a basis swords are the
most all-round weapon on offer with the
ability to unleash elemental combos the
slowest weapon is the hammer but it hits
damn hard too and has the ability to
stagger the behemoths
allowing for extra slashing time from
others in the group the hammer also has
a hidden weapon a cannon built inside
give it a try it's damn cool
I find the hammer is the most
complementary weapon on offer and I
personally I'm always delighted when I
see someone rocking a hammer in the crew
the fastest weapon to harnessed are the
chain blades which operate just like
they did in the God of War series the
caveat though is the drop in attack
damage but the speed that these bad boys
can be swelled around in it's astounding
the chain blades can be used at both
close and medium range with an added
ability to leap towards or to quickly
leap away in moments of peril the axe is
an extremely slow weapon to yield of
making knowledge of how long an attack
will take paramount the axe can be
charged up to add extra devastation but
once again knowledge of timing is the
crux of this weapon the war Pike
requires more dedication than other
weapons due to the attack meter building
up which adds the projectile to your
arsenal this meter can be claimed at any
point but the projectile will not be as
impactful if the meter is unfinished
the latest weapon to be added to the
game are the repeaters two hand cannons
for ranged attacks let's not go any
deeper just yet I'll be uploading a
weapon breakdown very soon
check back for that
so now we know about the enemy and we
know about the tools of our trade but
how is all that presented in our hook
town of Ramsgate before and after every
mission this is our home NPCs are here
to interact with upgrade equipment craft
weapons and armor but he is the greatest
thing of all there are dogs chilling out
go on go pet the little bugger before I
waste three hours petting a digital dog
let's look around just northeast of the
main square is our smithy this chap is
the one who builds the weapons we use as
long as we have the correct materials of
course same goes for this young lady who
will build our armor
by the way armor is available in four
types the helm the torso the gloves and
the legs armor is primarily made from
the dead behemoths we constantly execute
so if you're missing one item to make
that helm simply jump over to the bounty
board and go back on the hunt a huge
part of games like this is the fashion
element usually found in the end game
we want our Slayers to look perfect to
be our perfect avatar here in dauntless
we have the ability to dye our clothing
with a mixture of standard and premium
colors that's all well and good
pretty damn useful but the real headline
in dauntless is transmogrification put
bluntly your favorite sword may not tie
into the look of your character with
transmog we can take that weapon and
change its appearance without changing
its attributes in dauntless you won't be
forced to decide if you want to look
good or have the best equipment this
should result in very different
characters running around the city
okay so let's talk about the elephant in
the room over the past ten years we've
all learned to be skeptical of
free-to-play games due to pay2win
mechanics well hear this in many
interviews dauntless devs Phoenix labs
have confirmed that there are no pay2win
mechanics at work in dauntless and there
will be none of those predatory loot
boxes either hallelujah instead
dauntless have gone down the hunting
pass route with a premium version
available
it's mirrors fortnight in many ways our
apex legends we buy enough platinum
which is the in-game currency and once
unlocked 50 tiers of items are there to
be worked towards I've been owning
everything in the elite battle pass and
can certainly see the desire to stand
out from the crowd with a host of dies
armor sets and emotes check out this
Quicksilver armored die it may be the
only thing to take me away from
bubblegum pink with the addition of
transmog the hunt pass becomes more
desirable on top of that our augment
cause the Platinum currency we talked
about
sigils and even flares we throw up in
battle Marvel enough to make our Slayers
look and feel the way we want them to in
this season's hunt fast
there's transmog ninja attire and yes I
made it pink if you're new around these
parts I like pink it's a masculine color
alright don't judge me there is also a
star front in game to offer other unique
items with rotating content and a few
relics from the seasons that came before
us so if you want to stand out from the
crowd the option is definitely here as
I've been playing the pre-release build
of dauntless what console the main thing
about the game hasn't been showcased
very well working as a hunting
without a doubt this will be the element
which makes you return for more meeting
up with friends or making new ones on
the battlefield I definitely recommend
playing alone for the first hour at
least as you understand the mechanics
but once you've got down those basics
play with others debating tactics are
deciding which weapons complement one
another and of course robbing the hunt
pass items in their face it's the best
part of these types of games ok so I
paddled on for long enough of one last
thing did you know that there is an epic
game support a greater code which goes
with this game if you fancy helping me
write in a Damari with a da ma are you
when you buy the hunt pass it will help
me make more videos like this one anyway
I'm sure you're sick of me I'll get
tough to be a horse hopefully I'll see
you on the battlefields hunting
behemoths together I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]